now how often you get chance to
sacrifice on E6 in the main line and
that is against not only one two but
four different black popular choices
sounds very interesting right
welcome guys as you are going to witness
some of the cool sacrifices on E6 in the
mainline nostrils
[Music]
thank you
the critical position arises after the
following mortar E4 C5 Knight to F3 D6
D4 C captures D4 Knight captures D4
Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and now A6
starting point of the nostrils
okay we are going to continue with the
main line Bishop to G5 whereupon black
has two choices
the old move in this position is E6 and
against this I recommend the move F4 and
if you remember I have covered this line
in detail in my dirty chess tricks
against Sicilian part 2 episode so if
you haven't checked it out I strongly
recommend you to go through this video
however in the recent time the modern
move is Knight B to D7
defending the Knight and remain flexible
okay we are going to continue with
Bishop to C4
well it is very natural for any notched
or player that as soon as that Bishop
arrives on the C4 Square they literally
block it with E6
as you can confirm by the database
well after this I recommend you should
castle and we have reached to the
critical position
where I want you to look at the database
all top four choices by the black leads
to our superb sacrifice on the E6 Square
where almost in all games
white finish the black very quickly
so let's see each by Tone and find out
how crafty this sacrifice can turn out
for you
the first move I want to consider is
Bishop to E7
Top Choice by black but a mistake as yup
we are going to deliver the surprise
package bishop
and the point is we are clear upon up so
if black doesn't take it then of course
white enjoy the material advantage
so no majority of the case is black took
this bishop and after this we can simply
take on E6 with our Knight and the
roller coaster start from here as black
has two major choices but it doesn't
bother to us as both leads to the same
disaster
so briefly if they play Queen E5 we can
play Bishop to D2
trying to get Discovery so black has to
move the queen out and after that Knight
to D5 goes into the main idea
well the same story goes
if they continue with Queen to B6 s in
more or less against all this line we
are going to deliver Knight to D5
which has two purpose number one it
looking at the juicy C7 square and
number two it attacked the queen
so white response is false he has to
eliminate this dangerous night
but after this I am afraid black Journey
ends here
well before I move on guys I like you to
pause this video and find out a killer
sequence where white finish off the
black
are you ready let's get started the
first movie is Knight captures G7 check
and after King to F7 we have this lovely
Queen check
which more or less Force the response as
black simply cannot take this Knight in
the view of following forcing mate
yup you got it Bishop at six King G8 and
queen capsules D5 a pictures chat mate
so that means at this point black is
forced to play King to G8
but after this I propose white should
play Knight to fi and this can create so
many problems for the black
for example there is a game in the
database where black who is nearly 2400
continue with Bishop to f8
whereupon White shows the power of his
position by going through this nice
sequence
first the snipe check
okay black has to take it
well after that Bishop takes at six
threatening similar Queen captures D5
made
so black stop it with Knight to F6
but after the following sequence
King to F7 Queen to G7 check and at the
end when white grabbed the rook in the
corner
black lost the game in few moves thanks
to his King caught in the center
so this game's highlight how good this
variation is for the world
activities
the second option I want to consider is
B5
here the same old Story We sack on E6
and after Pawn takes E6 Knight takes E6
Queen to B6 do you remember what is the
plan
congratulations if you find the same
pattern Knight to D5
a double attack
so that this time around when blacks
take it
instead of capturing with the pawn white
has a better move namely Queen captures
D5
and recently I beat a candidate Master
quickly in the slide where my opponent
casually continued with Bishop to B7
which I'm afraid
a big time blunder
and after this
there is a mate in three guys yup
see how beautiful this line is as white
has this nice Finishing Touch Knight to
C7 check
King has no way to hide so black has to
take it but after Queen to E6 Bishop to
E7 and queen captures E7 we have a
deadliest Checkmate in this variation
which you should always watch out in
your own game
all right
the third move I want to consider is
Queen to C7
had no price for guessing is White's
next reply it is very obvious Bishop
takes E6
after Pawn takes and Knight takes
if Queen goes to either B6 or E5 Square
then we have Knight to D5 our familiar
territory
so in one of the game black choose the
move Queen to C4 counter-attacking the
White Knight
well it doesn't stop white plan namely
Knight to D5 looking at Juicy C7 Square
and after Knight xd5 and pawn takes D5
black choose the move Knight to IFA in
order to eliminate this dangerous Knight
but after just two moves black can pack
his bag and go home
would you like to try yourself
go ahead buddy I'm showing you right now
B3
Queen to C3 and now lovely deflection
move Bishop to D2 so that Queen has to
go to the only Square namely B2 and
after that yup you guessed it finally we
get the rook in the corner
last but not least what happens if black
plays the fourth popular choice namely
Knight to C5
and against this I recommend you should
start with B4
so that if Black Knight goes back then
we can achieve our familiar tactical
pattern
Bishop takes E6 Pawn takes E6 Knight
takes E6 Queen B6 Knight D5 Knight takes
Pawn takes and here it doesn't matter
whatever black plays let's say in one
game black continue with Knight to E5
trying to go for the same idea well this
time around once again white deflect the
queen with Bishop to E3 so that by force
Queen has to give up the C7 Square
whereupon this Fork is so strong that
white is winning in almost majority of
the games
so nope moving the Knight is too
dangerous for black
the only good move here is
counter-attacking the white Bishop with
B5
but against this I propose this nice
trap in this line starting with Pawn
Tech C5
B Tech C4
and now this wonderful sacrifice
night to defy
what a move
well simply black cannot allow this
Knight to go on a juicy B6 Square so he
has to take it off
but after this white has a nice counter
play which I like to show you by showing
a grand master game
where white crushed his feeding master
in a star
here he continued with e captures D5
looking for moves such as Rook to E1 and
Knight to C6
and black thought that okay let me
quickly Castle before apocalypse happens
so he continued with Bishop to E7
which I am afraid turn out is a big
mistake as after Knight to C6 Queen to
C7 and Rook to even
black to his horror find out that he is
about to lose his important pressure
well the game finished very quickly
black played Bishop to G4
attacking the White Queen White played
Queen to D4
so now the threat is Bishop takes F6 and
in some Line This G4 Bishop hangs
so black continue with crafty Moon
Bishop to E6
but Grandmaster was in the control of
all the tactics
and he kick start with Knight captures
E7
so that in the next move he can take the
bishop
okay black continue with in between move
D capture C5 attacking the White Queen
so white has to take on C4
and when black recaptured the piece
why deliver the following deadly
sequence
Bishop takes up six
Queen takes up six
now we take on C5 stopping Black to
Castle
and kindly note you cannot play Rook to
C8 as white can simply take it off
so in the game black choose Rook to d8
attacking on D5
but now the task is very easy you first
give this check misplace the black king
and then take this piece whereupon
the only mistake white should avoid is
not taking on E6 and wisely so white
played Rook to B1 where if you carefully
look at the position not only white is a
clear Pawn up but black king and this
Rook is completely misplaced and on top
of everything white has Rook intrusion
coming up on the B7 Square
where all together black has a
completely hopeless position
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile sacrificial line
in the main line nostov
the most fascinating part is
all the Top Choice from the black allow
us this beautiful sacrifice and after
this as I have demonstrated in this
video no matter however black Riggles
white quick opening Victory cannot be
denied
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
buy and take care